welcome everybody to the last day of the
beyond the bullion Cube Workshop so our
first Speaker today is Bangalore and is
going to talk about linearity testing of
the PBS Cube so take it away okay yeah
thanks
um yeah so I'll be talking about testing
linearity or uh or the bioscope and this
is a joint work with subash code and
Dora means that
um
yeah so in this talk we'll be dealing
with functions from 0 1 to the N to
reals although the workshop is called
beyond the Boolean hypercube we'll just
be talking about functions on the
Boolean hypertube
um and uh yeah F has a representation
you can break it up as as
of x
and and chias is basically these are all
the linear functions
what to do
okay and uh f f is correlated to a
linear function
if F hat of s is large in magnitude for
some s
right and S could be empty sets which is
just like it has some bias even that
even that function is correlated to a
linear function okay so that's uh that's
that and uh um so before we start
talking about uh linearity testing over
bios Cube um
we'll be interested in restriction of a
Boolean function so let me Define the
kind of restriction uh that we'll be
doing so
so let's say mu be a distribution
on just a bit
and let's say I can write mu as Alpha
time the uniform distribution
Plus
1 minus Alpha times the remaining
distribution
the remaining like residual distribution
so I'm just like isolating the uniform
distribution from the rest
and the restriction
which I'll be denoting by this I and z
okay so it is as follows first uh
select a subset
I of n
by including
a in I
so it's probability 1 minus Alpha
independently
okay so we are basically selecting a
subset of size 1 minus Alpha times n
and then select
C which is in 0 1 to the
n minus 0 into the I
according to the distribution new
and the restricted function so the
restricted function
which I am denoting it by f i restricted
to Z it is a function from 0 1
to the N minus I
to reals
this is defined as f
X is f evaluated at X
we are basically restricting the
coordinates from I according to Z and
then you have these y variables
f
we have this I here you are putting C uh
and then in N minus I
put in x
so that's that's the definition of a
restricted function
um
and we are interested in understanding
the properties of restricted functioning
you know what if we know something about
the restricted function can we do
something about the original function
okay so let me
Define so the question that we're
interested in
um if the restricted function
is correlated to a linear function
then what can we reduce about f
okay so that's the question
okay
um so so what can FP I mean f can be a
low degree function because if you just
restrict and in this talk I'll be
thinking about Alpha as some constant
you know like say 0.2 or something so we
are really restricting like constant
fraction of the coordinates
service and so so if the original
function is a low degree function then
if you if you do this restriction then
the bias of the function uh the
restricted function becomes large or the
function becomes constant most of the
time uh in which case the restricted
function is correlated to a linear
function right so low degree function is
one case f
can be a low degree function
and when it's a low degree function it's
the degrees independent of n some
constant just depending on
um yeah so in in in this talk all these
epsilons and deltas and etas they are
constant independent of n so we are
saying that once we do the Restriction f
is correlated to a linear function in
that sense then F can be a low degree
function where the degree just depends
on that
uh what is the another example
another example is f can be a linear
function
right I mean if you have linear function
if you just restrict a few coordinates
then the restricted function becomes a
linear function
and the main theorem that we show
is these are the only two cases
so let me write it more formally so uh
so probability over the Restriction I
and Z there exists s
such that the restricted function
is correlated to this linear function
it happens with significant probability
then
uh then f is correlated to
a product of
loading function and the linear function
because I mean it can be this it can be
so you can even combine these two
examples just take F at the
multiplication multiplication of loading
functional linear function and it still
has that property that with significant
non negligible probability the
restricted function is correlated to a
linear function
so is is the statement clear
so in other words we can write
and F Chi S and G
is large
where
um there is a linear function this is a
loading function and in fact we can also
take G to be just the low degree part of
this function
so any questions from the on the theorem
statement
okay so
um so the rest of the talk
um so this
so this is that this is the plan of the
rest of the talk
so one is uh I'll I'll show how to use
this theorem to prove linearity testing
or a bias Cube
application
to
United testing
or a biased queue
and second
I'll probably say a few words about how
we prove that theorem
so let me first Define this problem of
linearity testing and let me tell you
what what was known and what is new
so
so we are given this function f
from 0 1 to the n and in this case let
me switch it switch it back to zero one
the Boolean thing and we want to test
whether f is a linear function or F is
far from a linear function
and so this is an actual test so
select
x y uniformly at random
that Z to be X Plus Y and check
if F of Z is equal to f of x plus F of Y
right uh that's the blr unity test
and uh and there are two interesting
regime uh one is the high acceptance
probability and one is the low
acceptance probability
so the high acceptance probability
regime is called 99 to Gene
which is basically in the test so this
is a test if the test
process
with probability 1 minus Epsilon at
least you know Epsilon is a small
constant
then
reduce
that
f is close to a linear function
and there is one percent regime
which is the same
except that the test process is probably
half plus Epsilon Epsilon is some
constant greater than zero then deduce
that f is close to a low degree uh X is
close to a linear function right and
this was answered by Blum Ruby and Ruben
field in 90 and this was answered by
Larry copper Smith
I think in 96 or something
but
so we know uh so yeah so that's that's
what we know so let me move to the bias
linearity testing
what is this
so this is this is again the same
problem we want to test whether f is a
linear function or F is far from a
linear function but we are restricting
ourselves to uh the case where each of
the queries they are distributed
according to a p bias distribution so
here in this case each query is
distributed uniformly but in a biased
linearity testing we fix a bias
parameter p
foreign
and we are interested in a test where
each of the queries doesn't matter how
many uh how many places you query F add
but we want each of the queries to be P
biased okay
each query is distributed
according to
a p biased measure
okay
and
so let me tell you a bit of history
about what was known about the P biased
linear interesting and then we'll then
I'll State the main result or one of the
main results uh which is uh by biased
testing from this paper so known results
first one is by copper T and saraf
foreign
they gave a
or constant query linearity test
uh in the 99 regime
I mean if the test I mean they design a
test uh the I mean and the test query is
some constantly many points and if the
test passes the 31 my Epsilon then they
conclude that uh you know the the
function is correlated to a linear
function
yeah this is a different test here that
uh then
so I won't write the name
yes correlation
uh it just uh
in this case
yeah in the P baskets Coalition just
means that MP to the end is called it to
the correct
being launched
exactly because we are just doing like P
bias testing so everything sips on the P
pH level so there we ask whether f is
correlated to this correct or if x and
yep
X and Y and u p and Z One
no no so that's not the test this is
just like like an example of a test just
to motivate you know that was known and
here I didn't even tell you what the
test is uh for now but you know I just
defined it you know we want to test but
each query is distributed would be much
major but yeah that's not the best
um
yes so in the uniform case are the
elastic Theory X Y and Z right so zero
probability is but you do you want to
make sure that each that individual as
marginally is a uniform measure the new
B major
in this case p is a half but I I'll give
you a p which is 0.2 and then I need to
say in a test where each query is
distributed according to Mu P measure so
that's the bias name test
which is anything maybe other than half
and then I want each query to distribute
according to the big bias
the correlation you wrote according to
mupi the characters are now different uh
no it's the same the product of foreign
foreign
become trivial
uh we have a linearity testing for that
um no sorry no no but the correlation
still should be under P bias but the
queries don't need to be
uh then
yeah I mean it's not clear then because
if the queries are like uniform you are
really looking at just F defined over
the middle slice or you know what if I
can like choose like what if I can use
Randomness to choose the queries
I think still I mean you would still be
querying F uh over some slide I mean
within some slice and then you can
really put anything over here and your
test won't even like touch these points
right so first things
yeah if you have two function tests yeah
then you can but if each of the queries
like uniformly distributed then you
won't even touch like that's part of
that part of this life so it could be
anything
there's no correlation between the test
possibility and everything close to okay
okay
um so then so okay this is what we knew
and then uh the paper by David dinner
they gave a three query test
over a slice
which is a morally same as the P biased
I mean a slice meaning that you know you
you fixed a slice the cake slice and you
want all the cake all the queries to be
uh from the slice I feel that f is
really defined on the K slice and then
you want to understand whether this is
correlated to a linear function or not
and they gave a three query test or a
slice again which is similar to that but
in the 99 routine
okay and recently there's a paper by
dinner filmos and Harsha I think from 20
they gave a four query test
in the 99 percent teaching
I mean I already said that you know this
is moralism at the bias but what is new
I mean they didn't just give like a
linearity test they gave a 2 to the
2 to the D plus 1 query test
uh for low degree function for degree D
function
okay so if you just apply that to linear
you get that so okay so far we only knew
like linearity test or P bias cube in
the 99 percent regime and the main
theorem
and the main result is that we have
now a linear test or bioscope in the one
percent regime
uh but okay I mean there are somewhere
so uh fix we I mean it doesn't work for
any P so it works for p in between one
third and two third
that exists a four query
uh P biosity test
in the one percentage
and I mean as usual the test has perfect
completeness in the sense that ETF is
indeed a linear function that is
processed with body one if it passes
your with probably half plus Delta for
Delta greater than zero then we conclude
that f is correlated to a linear
function
so
um
so now let me try to just uh so this
this is the random restriction theorem
so in the next few minutes I'll just try
to motivate uh at least I mean my plan
is just to show that how to use this
theorem to prove something of this sort
you know and and the proof will be very
high level it's just that I just want to
highlight the connection between this
term and that theorem that's it
okay so
text
random restriction theorem
to biased linearity testing
okay
so uh so that's our test is for query uh
which can be defined as follows so you
have a distribution new
on 0 1 to the four
such that
uh a plus b plus C plus T is equal to 0
if
a b c d is in the support of new
and then we're going to
sample x y z w
from
0 1 to the n
the four queries such that
I mean coordinate Y is
a independent sample from new
and by definition because we have this
property that you know every Tuple which
is in the support of Nu the addition is
0 by definition we have
W is equal to X Plus y plus c
okay and the queries and test if
foreign
X Plus F of Y plus F of Z
okay so that's the test so we have a
distribution on four bits we just uh
four queries are basically
coordinate wise we just put like
a sample from mu and then you just
repeat it 10 times
okay and for technical reason uh we want
mu to be pairwise independent and that's
the reason we have these conditions on I
mean this condition on P
okay
okay ready yeah and definitely yeah yeah
and
marginally
G biased okay so if you have this
condition
um
yeah you can't have like less than one
third and pairwise independent
distribution but any P if you give me
any pin between one third and two third
I can have such a distribution which is
independent and marginally it is p
biased so all my queries will be P
biased on the previous measure okay
[Music]
it's a question okay
okay so now let's let's say we have this
function given
and
now in this case I'll switch to plus one
minus one word
and F passes the test
probability at least half plus Delta
Delta is some constant greater than zero
okay now this can be written as this
expectation over x y z w
f of x f of Y
from z f of w is at least Delta
if it's a result that may be still
double to
okay
um
now now now
now the the thing that we I mean the
main thing that we would like to do is
that somehow we would want to we would
want to analyze such an expression where
each query is distributed uniformly
because we know how to uh analyze such a
test which is really the four query nit
test where each query is uniform like
XYZ uniform and Z is equal to X Plus y
plus Z we know how to analyze such tests
right so uh so that's how we uh so in
order to reduce to that case we'll write
new as from alpha times the uniform
Distribution on the four bits
Plus 1 minus Alpha times the residual
distribution
and what we will do is we'll first
choose some 1 minus Alpha fraction of
the coordinates
independently like you know and then set
these these values according to new
tilde
okay and then on the remaining
coordinate we'll just sample like a
uniform 4 bit string because addition is
zero
so I can write this as expectation over
I
which is 1 minus Alpha times n
uh then
I have a b
c d these are the restrictions and then
I have another X
Prime y Prime Z Prime W Prime
F of
a x f of
b y Prime F of c z Prime F of d w Prime
okay so I didn't really do anything I
just changed so here it was according to
new tensor n so ABCD is they are
according to new field.enser n and these
are according not n maybe I and this is
according to the uniform distribution
it's not really the uniform uniform or
a plus
e plus C plus T is equal to zero
okay so this is our uniform insert I
n minus
right but again I mean in picture it
just says that it just means that
I first select these Corners then fill
in these entry according to new tilde
and then the remaining I just filled in
according to the uniform distribution of
the four bits
now this expression this is really the
Restriction of f
this is really the Restriction I mean
you can really think of this as
restricting the I coordinates of f to a
and restricting the I coordinates I mean
coordinates from I to B and C and so on
so this is same as for a typical iron I
this is same as
Prime y Prime C Prime W Prime
this according to the uniform
distribution
foreign
right so far so good
and and now and now here x Prime y Prime
Z Prime W Prime they are distributed
uniformly according to the uh where I
mean each square is uniform here x Prime
is uniform y Prime is uniform Z Prime is
uniform and W Prime is just the sum of
this which is also uniform and we know
how to analyze such an expression from
this we can conclude
uh May write it
foreign
so from this we can conclude
that
for
a typical
I and a
h
it's large
and this is just the I mean this is
again the standard linearity testing
yes
they are not independent I mean you can
think of X Prime y Prime Z prime or
independent and W Prime is just
then the original distribution was only
an allies
um
it's a miracle
it's a miracle what happens when p is
equal to one half then all of them
become independent calculated
I mean you is a uniform distribution
over the support right
why it's a support
um
I mean um so if if it is an independent
description then you have all these
things
well again I mean when I said new new
header full support by the way where a
plus b plus C plus T is equal to zero
okay
so I've selected you from a under the
condition that the sum is zero but still
each one separately is uniform actually
it's great
so so that's that's the conclusion that
we got that for a typical restriction
the restricted function is four related
to a linear function and that's where we
use the the main theorem that if we have
uh the condition that for a digital
restriction that is the recipient
contains related to a linear function
then the original function is coded to a
linear function and
um and and the low degree function so
from this we can conclude that what is
this expectation of
is1
is large
like Delta K but it's something
um okay so I mean so I did a very big
jump from this expression to that
expression right I mean all I all I all
I knew at this point is that f is called
related to such account such a product I
mean such a function but it did not be
the case that you know there are only
constantly many such product functions
if there are only constant remaining I
can write f as some of that that thing
this has some of that and then I can
just find one from each of these things
where I can replace f with this and
still hope that this expectation is
large
but you can still do some some sort of
argument where uh all of the correlated
all such correlated product functions
the size of that is small you know some
constant
okay but in general is not true yes the
the green theorem how is delta Prime
depending on uh other things like Delta
Epsilon so it's just some function of
Delta and Epsilon so yeah
so the order is like polynomial
um
so I don't quite remember the oh so is
it that is yeah here we didn't care
about the dependency but I think in the
next paper we have some uh
exponentially in 101 yeah
[Laughter]
okay so yeah so each of these functions
uh they are related to a product of low
degree and linear so we just moved from
this to that again I mean I I'm just
hiding something uh it's not I mean you
need to do something to cycle this thing
but you know let's say that can be done
and we also use the fact that GI this is
really F times i s i and the loading
part of that
and that's what the theorem gives them
and you can also take I mean it also
gives you a structure on the loading
part
so
um
so if expectation of GI is large
then you can conclude that f is
correlated to a character
right because
so if if these are the large bias it
means that X is equal to minus
so you assume that all the expectations
are small uh we can also conclude we can
also from this expression can also
conclude that all the SI they are
essentially they should essentially be
the same you can't have like very
different sis because then there is some
Randomness in the coordinate that is
left and then this expression will
become very small so all I'm saying is
that uh s i
s k this is small again small just means
some constant independent
so this expression essentially boils
down to some low degree function
G2 G3 and G4 Bangalore
so again I mean I just I mean so the
main thing is that this is the step
where we use the random restriction
table and then from that we can do that
you know now we have a product uploading
the functions with expectation and the
expected product of loading functions is
large right and now this can't be true
because
right hand is the true
I mean I mean there's a big hammer
that we need to use but this leads to a
contradiction
everything Hammer is the most ingredient
so we know that uh each expectation is
small so by invariance principle
and assuming and using the fact that the
distribution knew was wherever is
independent this is same as product of
expectation
and yes here we assume here we need that
newspaper independent
okay
um yeah and once you do that this
expression is small because you assume
that all the expectations all the biases
are small
right and that leads to conversion
so okay I mean I did a lot of hand baby
stuff but I just want to point out a few
technicalities so you can't really apply
more cells in there is principle for
these functions because these are just
considered functions so they are not
bounded okay but that can be taken care
of by using some noise operator another
technical issue is that you need the
functions to have low influences
right to apply the invariance principle
uh and again that can be uh that can be
done by restricting a few coordinates
um few inferential coordinates from
these functions and also we also assume
that GIS they are not uh correlated
linear functions to begin with right and
because of that property we can restrict
like some constantly many coordinates
and make sure that all the influences
are small uh the boundedness can also be
taken care of and
after that you apply the most cells in
the instruments
so that's the proof of
biased linearity testing
um assuming assuming this this theorem
so any question
yes
let's say take five like a five and then
I check whether like C5 is yes
no I mean it will still be I mean
I mean analysis would be the same but
you you will end up querying file
locations
so typically the number of queries also
important so I mean you want the number
of ways to get responsibility
so yeah if you are willing to increase
your number of queries then you will get
the linearity test for different piece
yeah right I mean all we want is some
some distribution uh such that it is
okay so I still have 20 minutes so
um in the remaining 20 minutes I'll try
to basically sketch a proof of this
theorem
and again the sketch will be very high
level it's it's not going to be
I mean okay so the whole point of uh now
actually proving this is to introduce
some direct product testing statement
um so if I can just do that I think that
would be good so that's my aim just to
analyze this and leave it at some point
where uh you need some direct Road
testing result and then I'll just
probably leave the weather
[Music]
thank you
foreign
I
won't really draw anything uh so let's
see so what what kind of condition we
have the
the assumption is that for typical
restriction there is a full equation
which is large okay
so these are I mean these are my
coordinates one to n and for a typical
restriction I
and z
and Z I have some Fourier coefficient
which is large this is the set s
okay so this just means that F hat of I
restricted to Z and S is large
uh you can say that
if so assuming if H hat of T is large
then for a restriction h j restricted to
Y at T intersection J complement is also
large
all I'm saying is that if you have a if
you have if an original function if some
Fourier coefficient is large then if you
restrict a few coordinates then the same
Fourier coefficient stays large in the
restricted function
with some decent probability
so using that using this fact
we can conclude that
there was this I
see and if you further restrict some
other coordinates I prime to some other
Z Prime then the same part of s it stays
heavy in the restricted function so
I to z i Prime to Z Prime
as intersection
is large
sorry so it's better to write as
subscript i z because
all right right so s depends on ing
yeah sure
yeah I mean this will depend on ions
and uh again this is a typical scenario
it just means that if you select I
randomly and I prime randomly and then
select Z and Z Prime then typically this
will be large starting from our original
condition so
and then if you use washer shorts then
uh you get that not only this happens
you can also re-randomize the Z Prime
part here
see hi
I prime Z Prime and then you can still
hope that the same coefficient stays
heavy in that
so here I'm just re-randomizing
the restriction
who I plane
do you see this
this is probably just some question I
mean Jensen not one with City positions
so what does that tell us so if you have
this set I and I Prime and there is this
restriction where you restrict I part to
Z and I prime part to Z Prime and in
this restriction you are sticking I part
to the same Z and I prime to some other
g double Prime and the same coefficient
stays heavy in both the restrictions
okay which just means that uh for I
Union I Prime
typical restriction
uh for a typical restriction Z 3 Prime
the same four equation stays heavy
sorry what is the question
in this case
I mean I mean in a
so you can't have several Food Equipment
those are heavy too often
so yeah I mean I'm
a normal person bounded you know so
whenever I say this thing this happens
also with some non-alitable properties
so
deposit
yes
okay so why is this why is this true
because I mean if for iron and I prime
if the set of Z tilders for which the
restricted function is foreign
and a correlated copy of gz Prime then
it goes out of this window but it I mean
but we know that that's not true I mean
even if you take the whole 80 copies the
full equation space stays large
so we can really Define uh now we can
really forget about z z Prime and z z
double Prime uh so for I Union I Prime
collect
all the heavy Fourier coefficients
and when I say heavy it it means that it
stays heavy for a typical restriction
and then you can say that this list is
bounded
uh
so okay so I'm I'm going to now State
this fact again which I'm not going to
prove and hopefully this is the end of
you know hand wavy stuff and then we'll
uh I'll State the direct product result
so that's that's the last hand wave we
start so you have I and you have this I
prime okay and then we said that you
know there is some for a coefficient T
that remains for a typical restriction
of I in an i Prime uh you can also say
that you can re-randomize the I prime
part let's say I choose I prime to be
this I double Prime and then the same
part of this coefficient it stays heavy
in this restriction
yeah
so the same thing stays heavy so if you
look at the set of Y variables
and look at the four equation that was
heavy here and that was heavy here they
agree on the on the set of Y variables
okay and again this is some sort of
Quasi shorts kind of thing I mean I mean
you have to do it carefully but
so yeah so
okay so so if you believe me if you
believe that this happens which which is
saying that I'm I'm selecting I I prime
the same I and some I double Prime then
this sort of same four occupation stays
heavy for a typical restriction of I I
Prime and I I double Prime then we would
like to conclude something of this sort
you know
uh f is correlated to a character and
this is really a direct product testing
so how is that so uh
so I can define a function on and choose
uh n minus what are the size of I
I Prime
to
so all I want to do so I am I want to
define a map which is basically 0
everywhere and then one on the heavy
Fourier coefficient and 0 everywhere
for I and I prime I would get this bit
string and for I I double Prime I would
get
0 0 0 1 1 1 1 1 0 0 0 0.
and and we have so if if I Define a map
like that you know I mean for a given i
i pen there are many such coefficients
bounded you just select one and then
assign that value here and the fact and
this condition that we are at it's same
as saying uh if you select a random I I
Prime and restrict this to
uh
so let me call this set the set of live
variables here is a and the set of Y
variables here is B so this is same as F
of a restricted to a intersection B is
same as F at B restricted to
a intersection B
so the set a is basically the set of Y
variables here
set B here is the set of Y variables
here
so we are basically assigning uh to a
set of Y variables the Fourier
coefficient which is heavy and this
property is at the same same four
equation stays heavy in a restriction
for I I Prime and I double prime it can
be stated as if you select uh these two
sets then on the intersection the result
the same chance that they agree with
each other
okay and this is really the I mean and
we are in the setting of the direct
product testing result so okay so I did
a lot of hand with stuff so but let me
just write now a clean statement of
direct product uh testing result that we
are interested in and that we can use
hopefully use here
um and uh and yeah and and then I'll
probably State a couple of results that
were known about the direct broadcasting
and what what is the difference between
our result and that reason
so any questions so far
okay so what is the setup for a direct
broadcast you have a table which is
defined on every case I set
it gives every subset of size k a string
from 0 1 to the K and you should really
think of this as assigning bits to like
the coordinates in s
and you want to test
if f is coming
from a global string
it just means that is there does there
exist a which is a bit from 0 1 to the N
such that F at s is really the
Restriction of a at s
okay this would be like the
okay so how do you test if a given map
is such a direct product there is an
actual test which is Select
A and B
uh from and from NQ scale data sets of
size K such that
the intersection size is say at least K
over 10.
and then check if F of
a
the intersection is same as F of B
and the intersection
okay so if that was indeed coming from a
global string then this would just be
the a at a intersection B and this would
be the string small a at a intersection
B and then you know this trick passes
right
okay so the known results at least
comparable results is uh
um
so this is result by dinor and
Goldenberg from 2008
says that
if the test
process
with probably Catalyst Epsilon
okay then f is
close to a direct product to a global
function
so let me just write down this so what
it means is that for at least uh some
Epsilon prime fraction offsets
F at s so okay there exists a global
function G from n to 0 1 which that for
at least some constant fraction of I
mean constant as in just the constant
depending on Epsilon fraction of the
sets this string agrees with
the global string
on all but constant constant fraction of
the coordinates so if I take the
probability or in s
I same h of I
at least 0.9
so it's important that you know the kind
of agreement they get here is that for
poly Epsilon fraction of the sets your
table agrees with the global string on
constant fraction of the coordinates
that's constant fraction
um
and another relevant test is so this is
like the test in one percent regime
and then there's another test by uh
dinner Harsha and filmus 20.
uh that says that if F passes
the test
with probability one minus Epsilon again
this is the 99 regime
right if the test passes with like
almost close to one quality then uh
there exists a global G
such that for at least
that for at least one minus some Epsilon
prime fraction of s uh here you get full
agreement F at s is in full agreement
with g at s
so okay so before setting our direct
product result that we need for this uh
just let's compare these two results so
this is in the low acceptance regime you
know it's like very weaker guarantee on
the table and then they conclude that
for
um some Epsilon prime fraction of the
sets the table agrees with the function
on constant fraction of the coordinates
and here the starting assumption is much
stronger you know the test passes
through probably one myself on and the
guarantee is also much stronger here it
says that for at least some 99 fraction
of the sets uh the table fully agrees
with the global function
what we show is that we show um
uh we we give a direct product test in a
one percent regime with a much stronger
confusion than that so let me just state
that
so uh in our case we we want we need K
to be some constant times n okay it
doesn't work for any K in fact yeah
in our setting K some constant times n
uh Q is a constant
uh what we show is that if again the
same test
passed
process
probability
is Epsilon which is some constant
independent of n
uh
then
there exists a global
function G
that's that
for at least
one prime fraction of the sets s
again this Epsilon Prime is just some
function of Epsilon
this agrees with g
on all but some
many coordinates
so okay so the difference between this
and that is that here the guarantee is
on constant fraction of the coordinates
so there are still like some 0.1 times K
coordinates from s where they differ and
here we have a stronger guarantee we are
saying that F agrees with the global
function on all but constantly many
coordinates okay and that constantly
many coordinate it features into the
degree part of the Restriction the
random restriction theorem so I mean
that was needed because yeah so we
wanted the correlation to a low degree
function and a linear function so the
loading part is really coming from uh uh
this this this bound
okay and you cannot really hope uh such
kind of a stronger statement uh in this
region right the example is very easy to
construct
so
maybe I can just state that example so
you can define a table from and choose k
to 0 1 such 0 into the K where
F of a is you used so that you you fix
some Global function n
okay and now I'm defining the table F
which is which which is really G at a
plus I add a little bit of noise which
is a string from 0 to the K whose
support is
voltage some log one over Epsilon
I'm just like setting this table
According to some Global function but I
am adding some small Heming weight noise
in it now if you select your set a and b
okay then there's a poly Epsilon chance
that or Epsilon chance that the noise
will not appear in the intersection
and the table will I mean this table
will pass this test with body Epsilon
but there is no Global function where F
agrees on all all the coordinates
um okay so that's uh that's I think yeah
so let me let me in my talk here
foreign
[Music]
then yeah you can do that
it's required test
Equity you don't have paverses
independent on three query
so
that is still
so easy to even
theoretically possible theoretically
possible
I don't know making it I don't know
your quiz
uh let us be bias and I mean you can
always do something of this sort right
so you have this coordinates you just
first select some 2p coordinates and
then inside that do your usual blr test
right
um so each query is B bias and you can
get that this is correlated but then you
need to like lift it up to your original
function so that it's not clear
and more questions
yes why do you need the accuracy biased
uh I mean that's the definition of a
problem uh so I didn't really motivate
you know why why we want the queries to
be pre-biased because uh okay so we yeah
I mean p bias measure are used in many
things you know to understand traffic
thresholds uh craft properties it is
also used in many hearts not many but a
few hardness approximation results so
understanding some test over P biased
measure is is an important problem so so
that's the motivation for studying this
problem yeah
all right
don't know more questions let's think of
me again
for 30-30 minutes
is